welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss and as shocking as it was to watch
the scarlet witch massacre the
illuminati in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness all this was
nearly even more horrifying now that the
digital release and director commentary
is revealing some deleted scenes and
concept art rejected characters script
drafts and pitches that were just way
too dark for the final cut and because i
prefer to live in a timeline where
everyone is crying allow me to paint the
picture of the bloodbath in the freak
show that multiverse madness could have
been and maybe should have been so weeks
ago we learned that the film initially
opened with a dark alternate opening
scene following 616 mordo after the 2016
doctor strange film now tracking down
wanda maximoff and get in i actually
found a visual of this encounter in one
of the official posters showing mordo
his sword strapped to his back
approaching that same ruined home that
appears in the background of juana's
orchard hellscape and you could see a
demonic wanda staring out at him from
the window and now director sam raimi
explains what this scene was and why it
was cut he said michael had written an
early scene with chuatel where we saw
him in our universe 616 where he was the
mortar that we knew from doctor strange
one only he had been through many
battles since that he had a limp and he
was coming after the scarlet witch to
take her power because he knew she was
dark and terribly corrupted by the
darkhold she killed him and cut off his
head presented it to strange in a later
scene but it slowed the beginning down
too much and we had to lose it yeah it's
not so much the beheading it's one to
presenting this head too strange in the
later scene like a fresh melon in a
farmer's market actually i have focused
a lot on that random close-up of the
volkers apple crate in that orchard
scene and i am willing to bet that in
the original cut after wanda warped the
orchard back to its true state that
crate would have contained the seven
head of mordo this dark imagery evokes a
rejected premise from marcus mcfeely for
avengers end game that would have shown
the avengers returning from the time ice
to see an alternate reality thanos
sitting on a throne of skulls and
rolling to their feet the severed head
of captain america but mordo wasn't
gonna be the only savage kill in this
movie bringing us to the illuminati
sequence in the audio commentary michael
waldron revealed that hope van dyne wasp
was in a version of the illuminati of
this movie he said quote yeah i think i
watched aliens and was just thinking
about the way those marines get
massacred and yeah i was glad it worked
i think originally the wasp was in a
version of the illuminati and the wasp
shrunk down and flew at wanda and wanda
just clapped her hands and just smushed
the wasp in the first draft
yikes concept art from artist alexandria
manjarajiem shows an alternate version
of professor x's death where charles
stays in his green blazer and tries to
rescue wanda from the rubble while a
demonic scarlet witch stalks through
that rubble looking for him making this
more of an active cat and mouse scene as
opposed to what we saw in the movie a
looming red cloud with a demonic
exorcist wanted popping out of that
cloud to snap his neck or actually rip
his face in half there was also some
leaked previz concept art showing
strange being brought in by those ultron
centuries in front of professor x except
this illuminati is less of the pristine
museum hall of the baxter foundation but
rather a grimier cramped room with
hexagonal sketches on the wall for the
six members of the illuminati there is
also a version of the sequence that
would have included an insane badass
wong helping wanda massacre all these
illuminati members waldron has pointed
out that it's kind of an unanswered
question where huang is in the 838
universe actually concept art from
artist dean sheriff showed an even more
flowery version of the 838 manhattan but
includes wong with doctor strange in
america meaning this would have been a
version of the movie in which wong was
not left in 616 with wanda waldron also
explained to her friends at the house of
our ring reverse podcast mallory rubin
and joanna robertson that one version of
wong would have been a vegas magician
turned schwarzenegger action hero my
very first draft had instead of wanda
throwing wong off the side of the
mountain she rewrites him but instead of
rewriting him sitcom style she rewrites
him into an 80s style action hero like
like arnold schwarzenegger and commando
and then she
she like uses she like takes him into
the dream walk and he possesses his 838
self when this version became
disillusioned with commerce and is just
a disgruntled vegas
magician so we called him vegas wong so
it was like him there was like a scene
of him performing magic on stage and
then going back smoking a cigarette and
then he gets possessed and basically
becomes this arnold schwarzenegger wong
he was with wanda
in the assault on the illuminati you may
have also seen in sheriff's concept art
a busker in 838 kind of like a bert from
mary poppins with a bunch of instruments
strapped to him i assume this is what
turned into the comedic cameo by bruce
campbell as the vendor pizza papa but at
one point there was a character named
melvin strange magician of strange
without any magic that might be why
pizza popping the scene accused 616
strange of stealing the strange wardrobe
from the strange museum by the way there
were a few alternate takes of bruce
campbell as pizza papa including one
from the post-credits scene ah
it's over
doctor strange
has not seen the last
of the pizza papa there were also a few
things removed from the multiverse
montage the frame store artists behind
this revealed that they removed a
universe based on the art of james
tyrell and in the cube world we actually
had to make the cubes that strange in
america divide into much larger and only
slowly separating from their face
because originally they went way too
small with the cubes showing more of the
bloody chunks of flesh on the other side
of the skin from the inside it just
basically looked like their bodies
exploding in the blood and it was
terrifying they also released the
deleted footage of strange and christine
from their past as surgeons doing an
interview for whih that of course is the
in-universe mcu news network about the
strange palmer method of removing part
of the spinal column to allow paralyzed
patients to walk again this actually
reads something more from the era of the
2016 film but might have been part of
the flashback of the memory lane bank in
838 when strange revisits his dinner
date with christine when she gave him
the watch waldron also detailed an
alternate ending or at least an ending
that more fully explains what happens in
the theatrical cuts ending waldron said
that the original plan was to answer the
question posed by this exchange how are
you feeling
why do you ask
you use the dark coded dreamwalk into
your own cards oh
yeah right there
fine
of course the theatrical indeed shows
strange's third eye opening as he
screams and then we cut to black but
according to waldron the original plan
was to show our 616 strange trapped in
the post-incursion universe and then
back at 616 who we thought was 616
strange turns around and that third eye
opens revealing him to be sinister
strange swapped places with our strange
followed by the laugh of the horror icon
vincent price echoing the final moment
of michael jackson's thriller so yes
sinister strange and 616 strange swapped
places and this is being reported as an
alternate ending but really i just think
it's an alternate sillier version of how
we are meant to interpret the ending
that we saw in the theatrical cut i
really think that is what happened here
when 616 strange collapses screaming in
that third eye opens i think that is
meant to suggest that sinister strange
who is left alive in the post-incursion
universe is now dreamwalking into 616's
body that because 616 strange used the
dark hall to dreamwalk into defender
strange's corpse and attached himself to
the souls of the damned that left 616's
body and his soul exposed to hijacking
even without the use of the darkhold but
this alternate version would have made
it a bit clearer exactly what was going
on here leaving 616 strange stranded in
the post-incursion universe which also
if you think about it would make it a
bit more menacing to see this three-eyed
strange teaming up with clia in the
second post-credits scene their
adventure into the dark dimension now
seems far less heroic and more
villainous this is a team of bad guys i
want to know from you which of these
scenes would you have preferred to have
stayed in the theatrical cut of the
movie follow me on instagram and twitter
at eavos following the rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you